[Music]
around the daily wire our founder Jeremy
boring likes to refer to himself as the
god king
rightly so I like it when people sort of
hail me as I walk by but none of us have
any actual claims to nobility any proper
titles and today I am joined by an
actual Archduke not only an Archduke but
the ambassador to the Holy See from
Hungary probably the greatest job in the
world I am joined by my friend
Edward Habsburg Edward thank you for
being here good morning so I
I have to congratulate you on something
not merely
on your very interesting career which
I'm sure we'll get into not merely on
writing a marvelous book which we'll
also get into you have done the
impossible
you have redeemed the genre of self-help
I despise self-help books and yet when I
cracked open your book it was
magnificent and I don't I don't know
even how to categorize it is it
self-help is it history is it a personal
Memoir is it
all of the above I would say if I tell
you how it came about you will
understand a bit better I was asked by a
friend whether I could write a book on
the habsburgs for the American public
for Sofia press
and I said okay I'll do that but I won't
just write a family history because
that's boring and there are very good
family histories so and then I remember
that I gave a talk in Boston
where I was supposed to speak about my
family and our values and the host told
me for God's sake don't just talk about
the Catholic favor of the habsburgs
because some of the guests tonight are
not Catholic so I said okay what what
else do we have and I began making a
list and
um and when when Sophia press wanted a
book I took that list out again and said
I think I have an idea
and then I began to research and while
researching these Seven Central
principles that our family stood for
I began thinking and I've been saying
this stuff isn't around as much as it
used to be these seven things are
perhaps something that has gone missing
today and then I said why don't I
propose each of these seven values to
people today and this this was a gradual
thing in the beginning I didn't plan out
to make this a self-help book but it
sort of evolved into that and it was
great fun and uh to and when I now so I
was on tour here in the states and when
I talk about these topics to American
readers
there is an incredible Echo they
understand what I'm talking about
and that's fantastic absolutely
fantastic you you come to the book not
only with this illustrious family and
not only with what you're doing now in
diplomacy but you've had kind of a
bizarre career
bizarre I would say in in only the best
way but you've worked in media you've
worked in Communications you've worked
in religious life you've kind of been
all over the place there was a New York
Times profile of you oh yes and it it
mentioned that you wrote a zombie movie
yes I wrote a really really cool zombie
movie it was set in Austria and it was
optioned I earned a little bit of money
and then like four-fifths of old
projects it never took off but one day
I'll see it I'll see it done you see I
have I have um I have six children and
with my growing number of children I had
to take different jobs to keep our
little family boat afloat so I worked
for a bishop as a spokesman I wrote a
thesis in philosophy on domestic
philosophy uh I made a TV series
um but for about seven eight years I was
a screenwriter
and before that I was a cartoon producer
animated cartoon producer I'm an
incredible cartoon fan and anime anime
fan which the greatest tweet I ever had
from the number of of clicks was simply
a frame from a Neon Genesis Evangelion
movie where I said that this is the last
place where you can see a classical
animation and people just freaked out
because Habsburg and weeb doesn't go
together no and uh but it does so you're
right I had a very checkered career
until
the Hungarian government asked me to
become Ambassador and I told them I'm
not your guy I'm not a respectable
Ambassador I wrote a zombie screenplay
I just can't believe that it took
bringing my Austrian Archduke friend
into the studio to make me hip with all
of these terms about anime and cartoons
and I don't really do you ever watch
anime do you know you know what the weeb
is I don't know what a weeb is that's a
fan of anime movies so that it all came
naturally I worked I worked at the
television
German company producing children's
television at the beginning of our
marriage and and then then I was sort of
hired by a company producing animated
cartoons and we I produced two animated
TV series and then I fell in love with
animation
and then I fell in love with screenplays
and so I got the screenwriting and then
when I was about seven years in with
screenwriting ahead one two movies
produced a few TV series where I had
participated I realized that with four
to five children you can't survive as a
writer and then I went to
to present myself to the bishop of
Austria which is a small diocese beside
Vienna and he happened to be the
pro-life Bishop of the Austrian Bishops
conference the one for bioethical
questions the one who has to speak up
when all the other Bishops take the
color of the wall because it's
unpleasant topics like euthanasia and
abortion and gay marriage and these
things then it was his job to speak up
and as he was someone who didn't enjoy
media and didn't enjoy sitting in front
of microphones he says why don't you
help me with this
so that my first job was to Simply meet
all the journalists in Austria whoever
write about church have coffee with them
win them over explain them what a bishop
does and explain to the bishop what they
need and my current job as Ambassador is
very similar I have to explain to the
holy see what Hungary does and to
Hungary what the Holy See does so yes it
it doesn't seem all to make sense but
actually it does right and if if you
read my book you will see that all the
topics
in there the Habsburg element fits
together with Hungarian Ambassador
element fits together with my Catholic
faith element and fits together with my
crazy career it it it all came together
no this is what really struck me about
it was
I
I don't like viewing history as just one
damn fact after another as some people
describe it it seems to me that if
history is going to have any meaning at
all then it's going to be tied
inextricably to the personal stories of
the people involved whose descendants we
see around us today it's going to be
tied to religion it's going to be tied
to things that matter it's going to be
tied to philosophy and government and
all the rest of it it's going to be tied
even to practical concerns such as how
do I feed my six children and so this is
the first of the rules that you lay out
in in the hapsurd way the first rule is
two parts get married and have lots of
children yes yes and you've done it
first of all in in script writing
there's a rule write what you know and
so
and I didn't want to begin with a
Catholic topic of Habsburg because I
didn't want to roll over those of my
readers who perhaps were not as
devouting as Catholic as I was so I
decided I begin with a marriage topic
historically the habsburgs are known for
their marriage politics for having lots
of children for marrying them off but in
my private life as you just said I got
married I had lots of children I thought
that I had lots of children until I
landed now here in the states and came
to my first Catholic dinner and and I
was presented and I'm used to you know
when I say I have six children in Europe
everybody says and and I came here and
the first three women I greeted told me
they have nine nine and ten children and
you could see a look of pity in their
eyes that I had six children a small
Catholic Family well perhaps the law
will give some more you know there was
something of not sad but no but what I'm
what I'm trying to say is my experience
in my life is that having lots of
children
is the greatest gift you can give
yourself your spouse and most of all the
children
each of those those children will will
it will be a gift to have more siblings
it sounds reactionary but it's reality
and I can tell now that my children are
between 14 and 26.
what kind of gang we have created what
kind of close close group where they
look after each other one of my central
experiences is and also the reason why
every state should encourage families to
have many children and you do this by
giving subsidies and by talking well
about numerous families you
um why every state should encourage this
is because around the dinner table you
learn all the virtues that you need to
build are just good and merciful state
you learn all of this and the more
siblings you have the better you learn
it you're always a bit hungry you're
always nervous whether you will get
enough to eat but you know that the
youngest child always gets first and
this is how you learn that the weakest
needs to be looked after and then you
know I've got one son and five daughters
so the conversation around the table was
always very Vivid and very loud and very
intense and the youngest wants to say
something and just doesn't get through
the noise and tries twice and then runs
out crying
the siblings learn we have to give a
voice to the youngest and not just to us
who are loud and if I am hungry I will
let the weakest eat first and you learn
from each other you listen to your
siblings you try to emulate what they do
you sometimes criticize it's it is if
you want the nucleus this is the place
where you build people who will build a
good and just Society tomorrow I think
it's far more difficult if you grow up
alone because especially now if you grow
up alone you will the the danger that
you will be slave to the screen slave to
your phone slave to every to every fat
that goes through through the world is
far great if you're in a family you
cannot afford that much you simply
cannot afford that much you have to
think twice before you go on a holiday
you are not so so easily swayed by money
by Fame by Fortune by luxury by con
consuming things because you have to
count you have to count your dollars so
all of that from my personal point of
view now for the habsburgs
um they're they're famous for marriage
politics
um why is that the case why did the haps
books from the very first moment of the
first haps we're becoming emperor of the
Holy Roman Empire Why did the habsburgs
didn't you know enlarge their empire by
conquest by bloody battles
um by attacking their neighbors
but by marriage politics
because
um the Holy Roman Empire is something
very different from uh from the Empire
we know from Star Wars
where one evil emperor suppresses an
entire galaxy and all the planets
through Stormtroopers
the holy woman Emperor was someone who
had he had Authority he had um he had a
quasi sacral status he was anointed
but he had no real power he had no
armies he had no money and he was to be
the judge the Supreme judge in the Holy
Roman Empire empire
and he was overseeing an incredibly
checkered and complicated chessboard of
different Duke stem Kingdom Prince them
languages legal systems
and his job basically was to keep peace
so
you can only do this by negotiation by
being diplomatic and the best way to
create peace with neighbors
is by marrying two children they come
into the family if you have a marriage
the chance that these two countries will
fight each other becomes smaller it was
very natural it was the only way he when
Rudolph Von Habsburg
our first
um King of the Holy Roman Empire in 1273
took over
um the crown
he had to put order into the Holy Roman
Empire that had Lain without Emperor for
25 years
and he was he rebuilt the law he rebuilt
everything he
but most of all he had to take back the
countries that have been had been taken
by local rulers during the absence of
the emperor
and in the end he had to do it by battle
but before that autocar of bohemia who
had basically stolen Austria large parts
of Austria from the empire
she tried to convince him he negotiated
he offered his children in marriage to
Israel that was this and only when that
didn't work out in the end he beat him
in the in the greatest nightly Battle of
the Middle Ages um during quote pretty
cool pretty cool and uh yeah so sorry I
was I was I was wondering well this
leads into another rule which is one
that I think a lot of Americans are
going to recoil at before they read the
chapter which is believe in the Empire
and Americans we say no we're
nationalists we want the nation state
the nation state is how you protect
people's rights and customs and the
empires all they ever do it's like Star
Wars they just come in and suppress
everybody and so we don't want any of
that yes well
what surprised me most when I wrote this
book was the amount of similar ideas in
the Habsburg Empire and in the United
States I reread uh talk will American
democracy before I came here and there
are principles that are very similar and
one principle is um the rule has two
parts believe in the Empire and in
subsidiarity I believe that subsidiarity
is one of the key words for our time it
is also the ultimate antidote to
globalism
and I think it is the answer to many
fears that people have nowadays and it
was the principle of the Habsburg Empire
even though many people including In
America which built its government
essentially on subsidiarity yes many
people don't know what it even means yes
but it's incredibly important so I give
you a definition of subsidiarity without
the word subsidiarity from the 16th
century uh Emperor Charles V he of an
Empire where the Sun never set uh ruling
over Spain and half of the world he told
his son Philip II if you rule over
several Nations you better respect their
laws their languages their rights their
legal systems their parliaments
and their special attitudes or you will
be in deep trouble
and so the Habs books always had to deal
with different
um Nations under them and whenever the
haps was respected every single one of
these nations and their languages and
their habits the Empire went well
whenever has was tried to centralize try
to build so to speak a very powerful
Federal level that that that that pulled
everything to you to a center
then there were problems in the Habsburg
Empire now the America is built
Grassroots up you're built around the
family Homestead county state and the
federal level at least in the beginning
was rather weak and the state is strong
you are United States you still are as
you could tell in the last two or three
years when some states just decided to
do things a bit differently than the
federal level would have wanted
this is also the experience in the
Habsburg Empire you you always have the
wish and desire of the Habsburg Emperor
to pull everything for instance Joseph
II Joseph II was one who really put his
foot in
um
his mother or not his mother married
teresia she with her 16 children we are
now in the year 1780.
um he admired Frederick of Prussia and
Frederick of Prussia had built a very
strong enlightened nation-state of
Prussia with one language one
centralized government like Like A
Clockwork and suddenly the their
economic problems were gone their army
was so Joseph II who was very he was a
fanboy of Frederick of Prussia who
wasn't who wouldn't yeah well well uh
well anyway I'm not my grandfather used
to say Frederick the second whom some
people call the great
um
and he said I will do the same thing in
Austria I want an enlightened Empire
where and what he did was introduce one
language
centralized everything to Vienna take
away all the local parliaments and
rights take away the crowns he took the
crown the Hungarian crown and brought it
to to Vienna and locked it away in the
shotskama in Vienna because we don't
need different crowns We Are One Empire
and that led to turmoil to rebellions to
anger
towards the end of his Empire he
realized that he had messed up and when
his brother followed him Leopold II he
tried to repair the worst damage that he
had done why am I saying all of this
because
the United States have to ReDiscover
this element in the European Union we
feel that we have the problem that
sometimes our friends in Brussels I'm
speaking now as Hungarian Ambassador put
on the other hat our friends in Brussels
want to interfere in our legislation in
Hungary yeah for instance one year ago
we made the legislation to keep gender
ideology out of schools away from minors
around schools
and there was Fury anger howling and and
and and accusations and we're still not
out of it
but they simply don't respect our
our legal uh institutions this law goes
with our laws and we have decided to do
so right so here you have a case where
subsidiarity would simply respect this
and um yes I can't help but notice in
the case of Hungary too
Hungary seems to be the only European
country
getting things right right now they're
the it's the only country that has
managed to turn around the birth rate
problem you've got declining birth rates
throughout the West including in America
and one country has has turned that
curve in the other direction you
mentioned earlier that one way to do
this is through subsidies and the
government just paying you if you have
if you have four kids okay you don't
have to pay income taxes let's say
exactly just hypothetically to pull the
policy out
so why is everyone beating up on Hungary
I guess that's why because Hungary is so
successful at resisting this wave of
liberalism well
you have to see that Hungary has two
elements one of them we have a
right-wing government that has been just
elected for the fourth time uh
consecutive and this time with more
voices than the last time sorry more
votes than the last time and we didn't
really expect it so Auburn must be doing
something right but he's a conservative
and that doesn't fit into a certain
narrative and the second reason is
Urban in a speech in Italy he said we
often hear from from the line and from
other European leaders Hungary and
Poland central European countries don't
stand for European values anymore
and then he said so I asked these people
if Schumer and the Gasper and Arna are
the founders of the European Union would
come back today where would they find
the European values in Brussels or in
Central Europe so Hungary simply
remained what Europe always was and what
were Our Roots and sovereignty Nation
faith family and Traditional Values and
the others didn't so it's natural that
we are we're a bit we're a bit uh the
bad guys the bad The Bad Boys in Europe
and the hungarians also
say things outright the way they feel
they don't chisel away until it you know
pleases the majority people like or a
bunches you know say what they think
he's a calvinist strong upright
Protestant and outspoken and uh and that
isn't exactly popular in Europe right
now it reminds me of this meme of you
know someone standing still you've got
the political left and the political
right he's standing still and then the
whole politics moves
to the right to the left right yes and
so now all of a sudden that person who
is a moderate now he's firmly on the
right Elon Musk said this about himself
Ronald Reagan said I didn't leave my
party the Democrats the party left yes
and so what you're saying is Hungary has
just remained kind of normal and the
rest of Europe has gone off on these
wild campaigns the fruits of which we
see before us there is a Gary Lawson
cartoon where you see the couch lying on
the on the no the cow lying on the couch
with a psychiatrist with her other and
all and psychiatrists taking notes and
the cow says of course it could be that
the rest of the herd has gone insane and
I think about that a lot right think
about that a lot well even
I I suppose the biggest problem with all
of this is that the Western Society now
seems untethered from any reality uh
moral reality theological reality now
even biological reality we've just
disconnected ourselves from that and one
of the rules in the book is stand for
Law and Justice yes
and we have lawlessness especially
throughout the United States it's
conveniently timed with the election
cycle just before the elections the mobs
start coming out the riots happen but
you see a breakdown of Law and Order and
I wonder if part of that is because the
modern liberal view of the law is that
the law is whatever we say that it is
yes yes I absolutely agree on this we we
have so grown accustomed to the idea
that um we can't trust our politicians
anymore and I think most people most
people would want to trust their
politicians they would want to have
upright upright people who stand for Law
and for order and who are ready to give
a lot for their for the voters but we
sort of lost their trust in a way and
that in my opinion also explains the
attraction for the habsburgs
um the habsburgs I mean of course I'm
biased but perhaps of rulers were by and
large really upright good law-abiding
people who who wanted to be there for
their subjects
um of course the figure symbolizing all
of this is blessed Emperor Carl Our Last
Emperor
um I I spoke with a with a spectator
journalist a few days ago he even know
who that was and outside of the Catholic
say bubble
nobody realized that after 70 years of
Emperor France Joseph at at the end of
the first world war there was another
Emperor there was another Emperor the
last absolute emperor in the Catholic
World he's a giant he's a humble giant
of Faith so he's been beatified which is
the first step on the way to being
canonized to say exactly he's been
beatified and if you look at his life
and that I think is the reason why last
year I went to to Dallas and I gave a
talk on blessed Emperor Carl in in a
hole there were 700 people in that room
I would say the majority were young they
were about 50 babies there were families
and everybody everybody loved blessed
Emperor Carl because I say because he
stands for all these values that we seem
to have lost a bit and he was incredibly
upright as a family father and as a
husband he was
incredibly upright as a in his job and
his job happened to be emperor in the
last one and a half years and and he
also
he did something that I've never heard
anywhere else when he went into Exile
and his countries had sent him into
Exile and he was on the island of madira
and he was
he walked one day and he looked over to
the church and then he said yes yes I
will do it and his wife asked him two or
three days later what was that about
and he said I have offered called my
life for my people
so they can have peace
and then later when he Lay Dying and he
had sort of a few weeks of of illness
and it was really painful and he really
really suffered he always repeated I
have to suffer so much so that my people
can be together and in peace
and he did this in prayer and so and you
know what what he did is also very
reachable for each one of us
he was a he lived his family life as a
Christian
he lived his job as a Christian the
social teaching of the church infused
everything he did as an emperor
um and he died like a Christian and
every one of us can do that we don't
have to do something gigantic this is
the things that you become a saint
through if you die like a Christian and
he did that if you offer up we this is
the last topic of my book of course die
well
um probably the most controversial by
modern standards because because today
we have a category called euthanasia
which literally means good death yes and
what do they mean by the good death
today the suicide Wow Wow in fact that
that that is you make a point I never
realized that euthanasia of course is
die well okay wow okay quite the
opposite of how we used to be in the
term there is there is a I I would come
with a painting
um you know there in the in this 15th
16th century there are quite a lot of
paintings of Saint Christopher the giant
that carries Jesus on his shoulder
across the water
why are there so many paintings of Saint
Christopher
he was considered to be the one who
keeps you from a bad death what was a
bad death
a sudden death now if you make a poll
among people how do you want to die I
would say 90 of the people would say
quick without knowing sudden without
suffering turn the lights off that was
that was the contrary of a good death in
the Christian 16th century a good death
was one where you had the time to
prepare yourself where you even might
suffer but you might offer this up which
would ease your way to heaven when you
died so you good death is neither a
sudden death without warning in sleep in
Sleep God please not and and it's
neither being switched off by somebody
a good death is accepting what God sends
your way with love because this is the
way you become a saint and that may be a
car crash and that may be a
long-suffering in a hospital bed
carried with prayer with love and with
acceptance this is the way how you
become a saint and blessed Carol did
just that did just that and this is
something that everyone can do you don't
have to be a superstar to do that and
most of all at the situation everybody
will be in it's one of the very few
certainties in our life is that we're
going to die and also that we don't know
how we're going to die so this is a big
Topic in my book and I
uh the story that touches me most among
my ancestors and well she's not an
ancestor but members of my family about
a good death is
um is a story I would like to tell that
story is the story of Marion to
Annette's death
a woman who is very unfairly maligned
who never said let them eat cake yeah
right this is one of those classical
fake quotes that have been proven to be
wrong but will never go away because
they are so wonderful because they
fulfill our prejudice
Marie Antoinette was not just queen of
France but she was a Habsburg she was
the daughter of Maria Theresa she of the
16 children and she was married off to
to marry the dofa of France the Future
King of France the future Louis XVI she
was devout instructed by her mother how
to say her prayers and she arrived in in
France and um and I think it was a good
marriage she had a slightly superficial
side she was a bit vain she wasn't
wearing gym shoes like in the Sofia
Coppola movie and she but but there was
that and she sort of I think she enjoyed
the court life quite a lot
but she was always a Catholic and when
then the revolution came and later came
and they were arrested and they were put
in prison and then her husband was
decapitated under the guillotine and
then it was her turn
she suffered because she couldn't go to
confession
the revolution wouldn't Grant her a
Catholic priest because all Catholic
priests in France if they were caught
were killed immediately so she couldn't
have a Catholic priest visiting her to
her confession that for her was horrible
because she hadn't confessed for a while
and she didn't know if she was in a
state of grace now just imagine just
imagine if this is a priority in your
life you're not terrified of death
you're terrified of not being a state of
grace right so she begged and she
pleaded and no didn't give her a priest
and the story is so nice because we
don't have it from her but we have it
from a very unsuspecting
um narrator and it's a book that
everybody should read once it's it's
written by Charles and he was the
Executioner of Paris from an old dynasty
of executioners and he wrote a book
about letter about his all the people
whose heads he cut off with the
guillotine Roberts Pierre or the
Revolutionary and also her it was
describes like how I came to get them
how we drove on our little card through
the cobblestone streets of Paris and and
what they said during those few minutes
until we got to the guillotine and how
they died halidad is always the same you
get laid down and
Chop Chop so yeah Chop Chop
um so with her he describes he was
sitting beside her and that's a moment
by the way that has been captured by
David by the famous painter there is a
sketch of her when she rolled by hands
tied behind her back
um with her hair rather short
and and so Saul said she was incredibly
nervous and unhappy and looking around
all the time at the houses
and really truly unhappy and he didn't
understand why well of course
and then they drove they drove past one
house and she looked up
and she was in peace and she remained in
peace all the way to the guillotine
Serene happy and in peace she walked up
the steps to the good teacher
accidentally stepped on his foot she
said excuse him that was her last war
what and then she was then she was
killed
and some soul never understood what what
happened so he went back and he looked
at the house
and After the Revolution underground
Catholics told him what had happened
and this is
it's incredible
Catholics knew that she had begged for a
priest and never got one so they they
sent her a message into the into the
prison that at a certain point on the
trip in a certain house but she didn't
know which one at one window
they would smuggle in a Catholic bishop
and he would give her an Absolution in
extremists
she saw it
everything was good
and why do I tell this story just to
tell you that even when habsburgs were
superficial
they had their priorities right
and being in a state of grace when you
die is a priority that's really
important and in my book you will find
other stories of that kind and that's
why I think that the chapter 7 die well
is is is the most the most important
chapter in my book and I could have put
it first because it it really shaped the
lives of most of the Habsburg Empress
not all a few of them unfortunately
didn't take this so serious and we know
this unfortunately it's very sad we have
to pray for them
but most of them did I can't help but
notice that we don't see death anywhere
today
we don't hold wakes really anymore we
rarely see dead bodies we hold these uh
degraded kinds of funerals where it'll
be long after the fact and we'll just we
just try to get the fact of death out of
our minds people pray to the god that
they often don't believe in to kill them
in the dead of night when they don't
know what's coming we take all sorts of
drugs to get it off of our mind and so
we can be happy that we don't see people
dropping down around us there's no
pestilence coming around no matter what
Dr fauci says but but the flip side of
that is what what are we what are we
living for you know I mean I I I will
die that is one thing that I know for
sure I will be forced to pay my taxes
and I will die and so it
I'm reminded of a line from Dr Johnson
which is depend upon it sir when a man
knows he's to be hanged in a fortnight
it concentrates the Mind wonderfully
it does and it focuses your life so if
we lose the the reality if we lose the
sense of the reality of our own deaths
yes
then how how do we order the whole rest
of our lives just sort of amuse
ourselves I guess
death was something normal up until very
few years ago now it's something
Anonymous in hospitals the only kind of
death we meet is terrorist attacks mass
shootings and act traffic accidents
um
you used to die in your family's house
with the children around praying that
used to be the normal way of death every
every young person had seen a
grandfather die and had prayed for them
had prayed awake at their at their body
um blessed Carol called in his son Otto
who told me when he was an old man that
he remembered exactly he called him in
an hour before he died while he was in
the Battle of dying and he said call him
in he has to see how an emperor dies so
yeah quite tough quite tough and it was
it was terrible for him terrible but he
said he has to see this he has to see
that you have to die as a Christian
um but what I'm trying to say is
um we have to get our priorities right
we know that we're going to die we
better prepare for it and
I believe that the moment of your death
plays a role for your eternal life I I
strongly believe this
and you can't say like okay when I'm
about to die or the time before I will
begin to pray and I will turn to God and
I will pray
is is like it's like jogging
you cannot begin to jog without uh you
can't begin to jog by watching videos
and you can't begin to jog without
training you have to begin and you have
to you have to train that all your life
if you want to run a marital and dying
is a marathon it's really a marathon so
um you have to prepare this all your
life the Habs books were acutely aware
they were also aware that their death
was public the way they died would be
reported to people and their their
subjects would know about this and they
would take their cues from the way the
Emperor died so you weren't even private
in death because your death would be
reported in all detail when you died
whether you went to the sacraments all
of that did you know that it reminds me
of a of a role of a father or a mother
and a family which is your when your
children around there is never even one
little Flinch on your face that can be
called private because the little kids
are always soaking up everything so the
words you use that and
we live in a culture that is obsessed
with privacy and it's sort of
paradoxical because we have cameras
everywhere or all of our lives and this
data go out everywhere but we we think
that we have a right to privacy all of
the time and then I think of cultures
that are a little bit more old school
the Italians come to mind where the
Italians don't have a word for privacy
yes the Italian word for privacy is La
privacy yes
uh so we're we're so obsessed now with
this idea that no I I have a right to do
whatever I want in the privacy of my own
mind and the privacy of my own home and
yet
what that can cause then is Scandal
which is an another word that we don't
really use much anymore now we talk
about it some celebrity goes to a
nightclub but Scandal is this is a
stumbling block that if if a ruler dies
in a humiliating and degrading way yes
if if a father or mother does something
that's humiliating integrating that is
going to scandalize yes the people
around them yes
we we are so on political we are built
for Community we are built for being
together with others we live in in a
world where our technocratic rulers our
our media our apps try to tell us you're
alone
you enjoy your life alone you live for
yourself you have to gratify all your
desires and you can afford it and this
is the way you become happy alone
family and living together and living on
top of each other is the absolute
antidote to that you cannot as you said
you cannot afford to get angry let all
your emotions run because you're
responsible for children around you who
watch you who learn from you who take
the Q3 who admire you and who will take
their ideas of life from from their
father so this the fact that's why also
why many people I don't think want to
get into marriage because they feel they
feel that they might have to give up
some of that total Liberty that you seem
to have now which of course doesn't make
you happy and the idea of committing for
life to someone else
and creating a family and having
children all around you which doesn't
allow you to do anything you had before
is so frightening I think mostly to to
men nowadays I think many women still
know that this is the thing and and
would like to that we have a crisis also
of marriages because people they don't
know who they are they don't know what
their roots are they don't know how
they're built we don't know that men and
women are different we don't know that
they are made for each other
complementary all these things we don't
know anymore there's only you the screen
and the account where you pay and that's
that's terrible that's terrible even
many people when they do get married
I've noticed this among
friends and acquaintances and people of
in my life they'll get married but
they'll say okay but
We're not gonna have children we're
going to chew some people can't have
children that's just the way enjoy life
that's right yeah we're just gonna go we
just want to travel or something or
they'll say well we're going to get
married but we're gonna have separate
bank accounts and we're going to and
they'll negotiate every aspect of their
marriage like it's an accounting firm
they'll refer to their spouse as a
partner a partner like I have here's my
business partner over here and here's my
home partner over here and and so
there's a holding back absolutely for
what in case of divorce okay it'll be
cleaner then well then why are you
getting married in the first place
getting married is losing yourself
getting married also entails that you
lose your total freedom that you had up
to them for another person for love and
for building something together that is
so hundred times greater than what you
have lived before that because it's open
for life it's open for children
it's so some people get together and
they you know they have a relationship
and they enjoy that part of it
but they won't have children and they
will put up having children put up
having children as if you couldn't enjoy
life anymore and each other anymore if
you have children it's absolutely
ridiculous and what what I feel is
having children was the greatest thing
in my life of course it is like up to
then you played the piano on one octave
like this but with children you you you
you you realize that you have two more
octaves here two more here you can use
your feet
it's it's incredible and that's what
we're Made for This is how humans live
for the last ten thousands of years
but some people just cut them off set
off and and then of course if people
live together and then have one child or
two children without really wanting
this goes horribly wrong it always goes
my my advice is
um
don't live together before marriage
don't have a sexual relationship before
marriage
check the other person out with your
racial intact have long talks about
whether you have the same values one of
the topics in my book in the marriage
chapter is about you should have the
same values the same ideas about
marriage the same Faith please it makes
things so much easier because men and
women are so different that if you have
the same faith it helps you have to
check all these things out
and you'll have decades time for sex
afterwards yeah you don't you know it's
not the most important thing in the
world yeah it's perfectly you know
enjoyable well yeah yeah but but you
know what you have here is a total
the priorities have been put on the head
yeah and people are lost and I love your
point on
how it's good to have the same values
and ultimately you know to come together
and really view life the same way and
agree on what reality is because when
there's a marital spat these are
sometimes in the news yeah
they're they're framed as a battle of
two Wills I want this and I want this
and whichever will is most uh expressive
is going to dominate the other will but
that's not really how A marital spat
should be it's not really how any
relationship should be in a civilized
society because we ought to be able to
use our reason to say and this isn't
just Pie in the Sky we I've actually put
this into practice and you're married I
went to my long-suffering wife who's
quite Sanctified every moment she's with
me but but you if you have a
disagreement about something you can use
your reason and say okay well here is
why I believe
that we ought to go to McDonald's
tonight well no here's why I believe we
ought to go to Burger King tonight or
whatever whatever the conflict is and
you can make an argument and if you
share the same premises if you say well
this is what men and women are made for
this is what our community is about this
is what God is like this is what we
believe and we ought to order Society
then you're much more likely to come to
a solution that will be acceptable yes
if you look at my chapter on marriage in
the Habsburg I have a rather
controversial uh chapter in it uh on the
famous inbreeding um because of course I
wasn't going to bring it up no sorry
yeah but I have to do it because it is
like Habsburg join inbreeding is two of
the things that I hear all the time on
Twitter when people think they want to
be funny or they want to provoke me they
throw something in or they draw a
picture of one of those half Strokes
with a lower lip and and they think
they're very witty and they think that
this time they really got me they really
got me but they don't of course so
and and there is you know what there
it's a fact in the 16th century and in
the 17th century
um there were two Habsburg lines there
was the Austrian line and there was the
Spanish line
they were cousins somehow
and what they did is over 150 years they
married quite often between those two
lines the reason was not some weird idea
of pure blood or something but this is
what I was taught in middle school I was
taught that the habsburgs in particular
but a lot of royalty and nobility they
all married their cousins because they
felt that they didn't want to pollute
their bloodline because filthy commoners
that was the Egyptian pharaohs that's
seven thousand years ago I'm talking
about the habsburgs they did this big
for two reasons well no for one reason
to keep the empire together to keep
those two branches together and in
communication and
but there was there was a side effect
and out of those I think 74 marriages
between Vienna and Spain
nearly all of these marriages were very
happy marriages for both spouses
now the circumstances are not what we
today would consider ideal you never met
your spouse until the day of your
wedding
um one you lived in Vienna they lived in
Spain you wrote each other's letters you
exchanged portraits
but you you never met actually then you
were shipped over had a long trip of
several months to meet your spouse
either to Vienna or to Spain and and
then you met for the first time and then
you were supposed to produce lots of
children and have a happy marriage and
um
but these marriages very often were very
happy now this is totally independent of
the whole genetic thing that I'll talk
in a minute about why
because they had the same set of values
they had the same Faith they had the
same idea about marriage
even the same sense of humor they came
from a similar world so I'm not saying
you you have to marry cousins which is
also something I get very often on
Twitter No but you have to find people
where these great criterias are then
your marriage will be easier more
fulfilling more wonderful because life
throws so many curveballs at you
if these things are settled
then you will have a wonderful marriage
it's not about marrying the person who
is most attractive at the moment but you
have as you said you have to switch on
your brain both sides and talk it
through and really get there do we agree
on this do we agree on this and yes
that's and just to get yes in indeed the
habsburgs
um they have the Spanish line of the
habsburgs died out because of genetic
disease and yes that came from
intermarrying too often
um in those 150 years but no and that's
very important and I insist on that the
Habsburg jaw that one
didn't come from intermarine now
everybody would say that's typical for
inbreeding yeah but it's not because if
you just Google
you will find that the helps with Joe
was already present two generations
above before the first Habsburg Spanish
Austrian marriages began and it simply
came from a grandmother of uh Emperor
Maximilian and it was a genetic disease
full stop had nothing to do with the
inbreeding so you know I always like to
put things right get some corrections it
is
it is amazing how much we've been taught
about history not just about the
habsburgs but about history broadly
there just isn't true you know and and
things that I was taught by my history
teachers in I don't know middle school
high school college all these places
that just and then you find out that
isn't true and then maybe sometimes you
find out the correction isn't true and
and there are these processes where we
go back and we revisit such things a lot
of people would say today year of Our
Lord 2023.
this stuff this is the past
oh the Habsburg way here are oh here are
the Habsburg rules you're going to die
well you're going to pray for a for a
long conscious death you're going to get
married and have lots of children in an
age where people don't even have two
children to replace themselves you're
going to what believe in the Empire
you're not allowed to say that naughty e
word the Empire what are you crazy and
then one of the one of your rules is be
brave and battle We're not gonna we're
not going to battle we're not in
braveries and that's for suckers we're
gonna stay at home and play video games
maybe we'll be brave on the computer
screen maybe yes what do you say this is
completely
Antiquated yes Edward how dare you
suggest this that was that was I think
also the line of the Slate magazine a
review of my book that led more or less
with um
um descendant of defunct uh royal family
he tries to give us life's lessons like
why would we even listen to this guy yes
you're right but I'm only saying things
that have been right for several ten
thousand years
you were saying things that have been
right since about five years
um have they been so right I don't know
who's that working out what I'm just
saying is you're courageous to go with
that if this was the human reality it's
like what I say to atheists I say you're
very courageous because you stand
against nearly the entire human history
back 30 000 years before Christ in cave
paintings they were all Transcendent
they believed in an afterlife
nearly every human being believed in an
afterlife and in life after death you're
very courageous if you're an atheist I
do wonder about just a little bit of
epistemic humility you know these people
who uh very modern and they say no we've
figured it out everybody for all of
human history thought one thing but I
figured out they're all complete idiots
and I'm right and I think I don't know
if I'm right about very much but I'm
willing to side with uh statistically
100 of the wise serious people from all
of history you just uh unwittingly
quoted my ancestor Charles V when he was
confronted with Luther at the diet of
worms because he decided to bring all
the empire together and to finally
discuss this whole Protestant
Reformation thing and he listened to the
arguments of Luther and then he said
um my family has for centuries stood
with a church and stood for Catholic
Truth for our lady for prayer and for
these things I would rather listen to
the voice of the church for the last
1500 years tend to what a professor from
Germany suddenly seems to think now and
then he declared him heretic it's a good
instinct
[Music]
everything in the past was better than
today this is ridiculous right but just
to totally condemn the last ten thousand
twenty thousand years just because they
didn't have internet and tick tock
that's arrogance also what do you think
what people in five years will say about
you
you are in the undertale how could you
still believe that there are only 64
genders
racist crazy
in Germany you say who marries Zeitgeist
will be widower very soon
um that's why one of the topics is know
who you are know your roots is one of
the chapters of my books know what you
are know where you come from and stand
by these values the Habs books were
always fiercely traditional in their
values and it's it's not that wrong yeah
yeah well before I let you go I I was
struck too on this very point
of humility by the funeral because
there are all these paradoxes that keep
popping up and the most glaring Paradox
to me is the humility of Emperors
including yes
yes and especially at the moment of
death yes I would like to tell two
stories about that because I feel that
that you really understand where the
habits came from when Queen Elizabeth
was buried
you have practically half of humanity
watching the most recent Queen Elizabeth
yes yeah number two that they always
have to add that not the other one no
yeah
um when her when her coffin was lowered
into the Crypt and the soldier played on
a trumpet this beautiful serenade and
they were reading out her titles
um
it was very touching but I thought the
hamstrings did it better and that that's
how I begin the chapter on the Habs
books and dying with the knocking ritual
that you can see on YouTube because it
was used not only in history but two
times in recent times when Empress Zeta
the last Empress of Austria-Hungary died
and I was present when that happened
um when that funeral happened and when
Otto died our last head of family both
times it was filmed and you can see
watch it on YouTube it's fantastic and
it in a nutshell explains the attitude
of the Habsburg Emperors about humility
so the coffin gets carried through the
cities streets of Vienna and you come to
the to the uh Neuer Markt and you have
the capacin church and the entrance to
the Crypt it's a door big door the
master ceremony walks up to the door
he knocks three times and the voice of
the Capuchin monk from inside says who
is there and he says Zita Emperors of
Austria queen of Hungary queen of
bohemia and then for about 20 seconds
all her titles
and the monk answers we don't know her
and then he knocks again and the second
time he says
all the achievements what the emperor
had done which countries he had
conquered which pieces he had made all
of this
we don't know her
and the third time Knox says who is
there
Zita a poor mortal sinner
and the door opens
and this is not just a ritual it is the
attitude the hab spokes were acutely
aware that they were poor mortal Sinners
all their lives even when they had
crowns when they had huge coats on
I wonder how many of our politicians are
aware that there are poor mortal Sinners
and how many of those nowadays political
leaders admit to that
um but the Habs books did that always
and I want to I want to end with a story
quite from the beginning from the 16th
century one of my favorite members of
the family is Maximilian the first the
last night one of the most grandiose and
dashing members of our family who won
the most beautiful princess in the world
and the richest and fought battles uh he
was magnificent when he died he gave
three Testament uh orders
for after his death that for me speak
volumes the first was he ordered his
corpse to be Sean his head shown tooth
broken out
and and flayed like our Christ at the at
the scorching
and then exposed like that
um on the on the beer before being and
he had portraits done of his face like
that and sent to All ends of the Empire
to show that the emperor is a poor
mortal sinner
grandiose it's it's alien to us now but
wow what a gesture there was always
there was always a teaching side of this
learn learn about this the second
gesture I've seen it with my own eyes he
ordered at his most beautiful code his
most beautiful armor was to be put up in
kneeling position in a Chapel of the
church in Innsbruck in front of the
Blessed Sacrament with folded hands the
armor the empty armor
for all eternity and if you go to
Innsbruck and you come into the church
and there is a right-hand side Chapel
you will find this armor kneeling in
front of the Blessed Sacrament now of
course maximia knew that armors can't
pray
but it was it was a sermon it was a
visible image that would teach people
how important it is to pray and how
important is Eucharistic devotion
but with a grandiose gesture yeah and
the third thing and I've also seen that
in Vietnam where he was buried he didn't
have a huge funeral Monument but when
you go into the church you will find the
steps leading up to the high altar
in that church from the 16th century and
the third step has just the word
maximilium on it
and that's where his coffin has been
pushed in and that's where his body lies
under the main altar
uh so that the priest would say Mars
above his heart above his his chest
praying for him every time a priest
would say master he would pray for him
I think that's fantastic now of course
he didn't count on the reforms of
Vatican II so now Masters don't happen
up there anymore
um but at the normal altar down there so
um yeah I'm not going to go down that
tangent that will be for the next time
you're in town because Edward I'll tell
you reading the book and hearing these
stories it's very easy to think wow that
old way of life that seems so foreign
that seems so distant and we live in
this new way of life now but but then
the question we have to ask ourselves
looking around dying civilization
everybody crazier than they've ever been
high rates of depression anxiety life
expectancy decreasing I just everything
things aren't working out very well and
you think well
maybe that old way of life has something
to recommend it and maybe maybe we ought
to reacquaint ourselves with that which
you can do in the Habsburg Way by
Archduke Edward Habsburg get the book
Now read it and then most importantly
put it into practice Edward thank you
for being here thank you Michael that
was a great talk
thank you
foreign